we don't have to wait much longer for
fallout 4 is far Harbor expansion but
you can get a sneak peek at some of the
quests and objectives right now thanks
to a leaked trophy list I'm Tony and
this is your offshore gamespot news
update for harbors trophies covered
quests exploration and crafting for
example you'll get one for discovering
20 locations and another for slaying 30
sea creatures some of the trophy
descriptions could be considered
spoilers so head to gamespot if you want
to see the full list in any case it's
interesting to note that six of the ten
leached trophies our quest related far
harbor is the largest DLC landmass
Bethesda has ever created and it seems
like there's quite a lot to do there far
harbour launches for ps4 xbox one and pc
on May nineteenth it'll cost you 25
bucks by itself or you can get it as
part of fallout 4 is fifty dollar season
pass this is fallout 4s third DLC pack
and Bethesda has said even more or on
the way to stay up to date with all the
fallout developments keep it locked to
gamespot
you